como mínimo
[Música]
y amplia nea enriquecer uranio al 20%
superando de lejos el umbral establecido
en el acuerdo nuclear de 2015 así lo
informó la agencia internacional de
energía el anuncio se produce en medio
de tensiones con eeuu y cuando el país
ya comienza a conmemorar el primer
aniversario de la muerte del general
qasem soleimani tenemos el reporte de
tetera
por primera vez durante la
administración trump el congreso de eeuu
pasó por encima de un veto presidencial
con una abrumadora mayoría el senado se
sumó a la decisión de la cámara baja
para anular la prohibición del
mandatario a la ley de defensa crece la
atención entre presidente saliente y su
propio partido cuando faltan sólo 18
días para que su vaivén llegue a la casa
blanca
a partir de hoy entrar a regir en 15
departamentos de francia la ampliación
del toque de queda de acuerdo a lo
anunciado por el gobierno
ahora la restricción iniciará a las 6 de
la tarde y se extenderá hasta las 6 de
la mañana esto en medio de un nuevo
repunte de contagios de cubrir 19 con
casi 2 millones setecientos mil casos y
cerca de 65 mil muertos
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en tras 24 mi nombre es
william a valencia iniciamos en irán
porque inspectores de la agencia
internacional de energía informaron que
la nación islámica planea aumentar la
tasa de enriquecimiento de su uranio al
20 por ciento muy por encima al umbral
establecido por el acuerdo nuclear de
el proceso se llevaría a cabo en la
planta subterránea de fondo aunque no se
sabe cuándo iniciará el anuncio llega en
medio de fuertes tensiones entre irán y
eeuu en los últimos días de donald trump
en la casa blanca quien retiró a su país
del acuerdo nuclear en 2018 se necesita
un horario enriquecido al 90% para poder
producir armas nucleares entretanto en
italia inician los actos de
conmemoración por el primer aniversario
del asesinato del general qasem
soleimani nuestra corresponsal en
teherán y catalina gómez ángel nos envió
previamente el siguiente reporte
si bien irá aquí el resto del mundo
conmemora el asesinato del general de
las fuerzas qods iraquíes casen suleimán
y el 3 de enero en irán se conmemora hoy
porque así lo recuerda el calendario
persa y así también lo recuerdan la
mayoría de los periódicos locales que
vienen con grandes fotos del general
qasem soleimani recordando lo que han
dicho la mayoría de las autoridades de
la república islámica y es que irán
vengar a la muerte de este general y
aseguran que tiene 48 personas en las
listas lideradas por el presidente de
los eeuu hasta hoy donald trump y es que
este aniversario también llega en un
momento de gran tensión con eeuu aquí
nadie descarta un posible enfrentamiento
en estas últimas tres semanas antes de
que trump se retire de la casa blanca'
la atención es muy grande especialmente
en irak donde los generales iraníes han
recordado a sus aliados locales
especialmente a esas milicias iraní pro
iraníes que conforman el frente de
movilización popular de que por favor no
realicen ninguna acción que pueda causar
la red
de eeuu recordemos que casi en su lema
'ni no solamente fue asesinado en bagdad
sino que con él también estaba quien era
el segundo de estas milicias aboal
mojantes que era uno de los grandes
aliados de irán en bagdad así que todo
el mundo
aquí en este país y en esta región del
mundo está pendiente de lo que pueda
suceder en estas últimas horas en un día
en que irán también conmemora hoy ahora
la muerte de quien fuera el ayatolá más
radical el que sigue la mayoría de estas
milicias mesbah yazdi que murió ayer en
teherán por complicaciones de salud
cambiamos de información porque eeuu
arrancó el 2021 rompiendo la barrera de
los 20 millones de casos confirmados por
ccoo y 19 en este contexto el presidente
saliente enfrenta una nueva derrota el
senado aprobó abrumadoramente anular el
veto presidencial a la ley de defensa la
cámara alta se sumó al voto de la cámara
de representantes y desoyó la
prohibición firmada por el mandatario
veamos el informe de juan rubiales
una sesión extraordinaria un 1o de enero
en un momento de máxima atención entre
los republicanos del congreso y el
presidente de now tramp el senado
siguiendo la línea de la cámara de
representantes desestimó por primera vez
un veto del mandatario con una sonora
mayoría la cámara alta mantuvo la ley de
defensa a la que se oponía trump
el magnate argumentaba entre otras cosas
que esa normativa no limitaba la
actividad de algunas redes sociales a
las que el presidente acusa de ser
imparciales esta negativa desató una ola
de rechazo en el congreso que había
aprobado esa ley después de meses de
negociaciones entre republicanos y
demócratas es una responsabilidad grande
pero también es una oportunidad tremenda
para encaminar nuestras prioridades de
seguridad nacional de reflejar la
determinación del pueblo estadounidense
y las amenazas crecientes a su seguridad
tanto en casa como en el exterior desde
twitter
calificó como patético lo ocurrido e
insistió además en que el congreso
apruebe una cuantía mayor en la paga de
ayuda a los estadounidenses en medio de
la pandemia
se ha alineado con los demócratas
quienes defienden un cheque de dos mil
dólares por persona frente a los
seiscientos que buscan los republicanos
el senado tiene la última palabra sobre
ese asunto y de momento los republicanos
han aplazado la votación tal es el nivel
de crispación que el jueves
trump adelantó un día su vuelta de
vacaciones desde florida en la antesala
de ese tira y afloja en el congreso
vamos a américa latina porque la
vicepresidenta de venezuela del sin
rodríguez anunció una cuarentena radical
de siete días para intentar contener la
expansión del coi 19 en el país la
medida empezará a regir a la medianoche
del 4 de enero y se extenderá hasta el
10 esto como parte del plan es 7 + 7 que
consiste en una particular cuarentena
intermitente con 7 días de confinamiento
seguidos de 7 días de apertura del
comercio el país relajó las medidas
durante el mes de diciembre pero
registró un repunte de contagios
llegando a los 113 mil 884 casos
confirmados y miles de 30 muertes según
las cifras oficiales
pasamos a francia donde debido al
aumento de casos de coronavirus 15
departamentos incrementaron su
restricción a partir de este sábado en
las regiones en cuestión se amplia el
toque de queda que ahora comenzará a las
6 de la tarde y no a las 8 de la noche y
durará hasta las 6 de la mañana el país
reporta ya más de 64 mil 700 muertes
desde el inicio de la pandemia veamos el
informe
a partir de este sábado estas calles en
la ciudad de nancy al noreste del país
estarán vacías a partir de las 6 de la
tarde
finalmente verifica si la medida es
efectiva yo prefiero esta medida a un
confinamiento durante el día para mí es
ridículo no importa si empieza el
ascenso a las 8 no va a cambiar nada por
el contrario forzar a más personas a ir
al comercio al mismo tiempo el nuevo
toque de queda de 6 de la tarde a 6 de
la mañana aplicará para estos 15
departamentos donde las infecciones por
coronavirus son más altas en otras
regiones el toque de queda actual desde
mediados de diciembre será mantenido
desde las 8 de la noche la medida
surgida por algunos alcaldes ante la
preocupación por un eventual colapso de
sus sistemas de salud muchos creen que
la situación sólo empeorará luego de las
fiestas de fin de año
el alcalde de nancy sin embargo cree que
medidas más estrictas deben ser
impuestas para minimizar la propagación
del virus
expósito la cual creo que ya es muy
tarde porque esperar hasta el inicio de
enero y probablemente no es suficiente
para depp
no estamos en el inicio del aumento de
incidencias tampoco al inicio de
incremento del número de pacientes hemos
visto esto en nancy y en el este desde
inicios de diciembre último de som
el viernes francia reporta un poco más
de 19 mil casos en 24 horas lo cual es 4
veces mayor a lo fijado por el gobierno
cuyo objetivo es de menos de 5000 casos
diarios el aumento de infecciones
también significa que los teatros los
cines y los conciertos no reabrirán el 7
de enero como se esperaba
por la policía francesa puso fin a una
enorme fiesta clandestina que reunió a
unas 2500 personas en la región de
bretaña un encuentro el encuentro se dio
en la localidad de leoganne cerca de la
ciudad de agra en desafiando las órdenes
de toque de queda de las restricciones a
las grandes aglomeraciones o
enfrentamientos con las autoridades el
ministro del interior llega al rahman y
confirmó que los asistentes fueron
multados y los organizadores serán
procesados ante la justicia
autoridades de salud en argentina
reportaron 317 eventos adversos en
personas que han sido inoculadas con la
fórmula rusa contra el coronavirus esto
entre un total de más de 32.000 que ya
recibieron la primera dosis
la campaña de vacunación en argentina
inició el pasado 29 de diciembre según
un informe del ministerio de salud el
44.2 por ciento de dichos eventos
adversos corresponde a síntomas como
fiebre o dolores de cabeza y musculares
los casos reportados corresponden al 1
por ciento de los inoculados
así finalizamos pero ustedes pueden
también visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ampliar esta
información en cuatro idiomas nos vemos
más adelante con más información
[Música]